a desperate plea from a las vegas woman
tonight who says valuables that cannot
be replaced were stolen from her car now
she is hoping that someone can help
figure out who took them victoria saha
now has the story they were all hanging
right here
and they were on long chains tammy angel
would always have a rosary hanging on
her rear view mirror made with her
sister's ashes her other sister and two
brothers ashes were kept in a canister
right by the driver's seat they're like
my guardian angels when i'm driving and
you know i say a little prayer but on
monday morning she realized someone
broke into her car and took the only
thing that was left of her family along
with a toolbox some cash and a safe i
just cried i don't think they realized
what they took angel says her door was
locked the night before but the thieves
got creative i think this part was bent
over a little bit more where they use
the slim jim and pop the lock she
believes the thieves took action during
the middle of the night there's supposed
to be security that patrols the parking
lot
but i've never seen security right after
that interview with angel we actually
ran into the security guard here
patrolling the area in his car i asked
him how often he's here he simply said
he's here a lot he also claimed he did
not know about the car being broken into
in that parking lot angel says she
searched all over the parking lot hoping
there would be something the thieves
left behind i just wish they would bring
me back my family you know everything
else is irrelevant victoria saha live
local now
angel is offering a 500 reward to anyone
who can help bring those personal items
back no questions asked